Oh Joe Biden launches his campaign
Democrats target president trunk with
investigations galore and the clown
princes of the right bachi hit on Pete
Buddha judge visit the ben shapiro show
o joseph our mcbride and he now has the
lead in all the polls and he is gaining
ground we'll talk about that in just one
second first let's talk about the post
office nobody really has time to go to
the post office you're busy who's got
time for all that traffic parking
lugging all your mail and packages it's
a real hassle which is why you need
stamps calm when the most popular
time-saving tools for small businesses
stamps calm eliminates trips to the post
office in saves you money with discounts
you can't get even at the post office
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the u.s. post office
directly to your computer whether you're
a small office sending invoices and
online seller shipping out products or
even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day stamps calm can handle it
all with ease simply use your computer
to print official US postage 24/7 for
any letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready just hand it to your mail
carrier or drop it in a mailbox it is
that simple
with stamps calm you get five cents off
every first-class stamp up to 40% off
Priority Mail not to mention it's a
fraction of the cost of those expensive
postage meters stamps.com is a
no-brainer it saves you time it saves
you money
it's no wonder over 700,000 small
businesses already use stamps calm which
is why I use stamps calm and daily water
use stamps calm and I encourage you to
use stamps calm right now my listeners
get a special offer it includes a four
week trial plus free postage and the
digital scale without any long-term
commitment just go to stamps calm click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage type in Shapiro that is stamps
calm enter Shapiro and try it out I
promise you you're gonna save yourself
time and money okay so yesterday was the
big moment for Joe Biden he has been
waiting all his life for this and by all
his life I mean since 1862 when Joe
Biden first ran for president he ran for
president in 1988 when I was four years
old he ran for president again in 2008
when I was I guess twenty four years old
and now he is running again and this
time he is leading the pack why is he
leading the pack well obviously because
who's Barack Obama's vice president that
means he has 100% name recognition now
it is worthwhile noting that vice
presidential candidates people who come
back from the vice
didn't see and then run again it doesn't
go great for them historically it
doesn't go great for them right off the
bat historically in 2003 in 2003 Joe
Lieberman was the actual Democratic
frontrunner in early polling data from
April 2003 remember is super early still
it is still April a year before the
primaries begin so we are still almost
two years out from the actual nature a
lead under these circumstances John
Kerry didn't even in 2004 at this point
in the race Howard Dean was ahead by
most national polling and then of course
Howard Dean imploded Joe Lieberman as I
say was ahead as of 2003 and then Joe
Lieberman started to fade and then
Howard Dean took over in 2008 2003 early
2004 and then he fell apart Wesley Clark
had a lead in that race in 2008 at this
point Hillary Clinton was the
prohibitive favorite Hillary Clinton was
by far the prohibitive favorite and then
of course Barack Obama came out of
nowhere and stole her nomination in 2012
Mitt Romney was the leader at the very
beginning he ended up being the leader
in the clubhouse but in the middle of
2012 he lost the lead several times Newt
Gingrich jumped into the lead at one
point there there a bunch of people who
had the lead for a brief little while in
2012 Herman Cain had the lead for a
brief little while in 2012 in 2016
Donald Trump was not the wired wire
leader Jeb Bush had the lead for a
little while
Trump eventually spiked into the lead
and then stayed there because of that
100% name recognition and because all of
his all of his negatives had already
been priced in so is Joe Biden more like
Joe Lieberman is he more like John Kerry
is he more like Howard Dean is he more
like Hillary Clinton like who does he
look like I would say that he looks most
like Hillary Clinton
he looks most like Hillary Clinton circa
2008 why because he was an establishment
pick a well-established establishment
pick with some pretty high negatives
when he gets out on the campaign trail
the reason that Biden has flamed out
repeatedly in presidential races is
because he's not actually a very good
campaigner he's good when he's
campaigning for somebody else because if
he's campaigning for Barack Obama
oh there's old jokey-joke campaigning
for the much more serious Barack Obama
when Joe Biden campaigns on his own
behalf he is not seen as a particularly
serious fellow now maybe the age maybe
the fact that
he has served as vice president for
eight years militates against that but
I've been saying for a while I will
continue to maintain I think that he is
a weaker candidate and most people
believe he is at this point if you are
taking the polls for granted at this
point I think that you're getting a
little bit bamboozled that said he might
be more durable than I think and it's
also possible that his name recognition
carries him to victory in a field that
has 1 million candidates well right now
well here's what the polls are showing
so Biden did get a significant bounce
out of his campaign rollout yesterday I
had suggested that he had not it turns
out then the new polls show I was wrong
he does have a significant bounce Biden
announced his bid last Thursday he held
his first rally on Monday in Pittsburgh
he is now the first choice of more than
a third of those who plan to participate
in their state's Democratic primary or
caucuses according to the morning
consult 36% of Democratic voters say
they prefer Joe Biden as the party's
nominee that is a six-point increase
that gives him a 14-point lead over
senator Bernie Sanders who maintains at
22 percent overall Elizabeth Warren is
starting to see a little bit of a boost
she is following at 9% followed closely
by mayor Pete Budaj at 8% Kamala Harris
at 7% in beta O'Rourke and 5% basically
that grouping is well behind both Biden
and Bernie and then of course you have
all these sort of Fringe contenders cory
booker has 3% club achar and andrew gang
both have 2% and then of course then you
have Kirsten Gillibrand who has 0%
because nobody wants Kirsten Gillibrand
that's always a given all of these polls
will show that only Kirsten Gillibrand
media family wants Kirsten Gillibrand to
be President there are interesting
cleavages in these polls so Biden's lead
among white voters 34% to 26% is much
smaller than his overall advantage he
has a commanding lead with black voters
44% to 20%
he had 44% for Biden 20% for Bernie and
Harris at 10 percent among Hispanic
voters Biden is leading Sanders by a
slim margin only 30 to 27 so basically
the entire lead for Joe Biden or a great
majority of the lead for Joe Biden is
with black voters that's deeply
important because obviously a temper
rock Obama won the nomination in 2008
over Hillary Clinton Hillary won white
voters running away Barack Obama won
black voters running away as well the
difference is that 60% of the Democratic
base in a lot of southern states is
black voters
so Joe Biden is heavily relying on that
Minority vote now Brock Obama came out
and endorsed Joe Biden it's a foregone
conclusion he's the nominee in all
likelihood but if he doesn't endorse Joe
Biden then there's gonna be a lot of
talk about Joe Biden's various racial
quandaries the fact is that Joe Biden
has a long record that record will
become the subject of Kamala Harris
attacks and Cory Booker's attacks in
particular they are hoping to steal away
that 44 percent of black support that
Joe Biden has in those polls Biden also
has the support of nearly half of
seniors 65 and older with 48% Sanders is
doing very poorly with those older
voters those older voters tend to be a
little bit more moderate which is why
Sanders is even running behind Budaj
edge among seniors 65 and older so
basically old people and black folks
really like Joe Biden and everybody else
sort of favors Bernie or is at least
very close to favoring Bernie Biden lead
Sanders by nine points among men 33 to
24 he has an 18 point lead among women
38 percent to 20 percent in other words
it looks like the Democratic Party base
is not the Twitter base but the question
is who is going to be running the show
when it comes to the actual primary
voting who's going to be running the
show when it comes to the campaign is it
going to be all the moderates who
supposedly were going to show up and put
Hillary Clinton over the top in 2008 or
is it gonna be the Bernie bros remember
Bernie Sanders did not pull nationally
on a comparable level with Hillary
Clinton in 2016 and yet he wanted an
enormous number of primaries what an
enormous number of Delegates that's
because number one Hillary was not a
good candidate and number two because
the people who tend to show up to the
polls and out size numbers are the most
excited people and those excited people
tend to be young white Millennials those
are the people who tend to show up in
primary voting for Democrats older folks
don't tend to show up as much in primary
voting and black folks don't tend to
show up as much in primary voting Biden
had a six-point bounce that tied Sanders
for the largest bump that morning
consult has measured around two
candidates announcements immediately
after Sanders launched his campaign he
vaulted 6 points and trailed Biden
narrowly 29% to 27 percent so Biden is
the front-runner for now that morning
consult weekly White House poll has a
slight drop for people who to judge who
may be maxing out and maybe the Peabody
judges momentum has stalled a little bit
and that Biden jumping in is picking up
all of the moderate momentum at this
point
that Biden pickup of six is coming from
Sanders who lost to Buddha judge who
lost one Harris who lost one a Roark who
lost one so that is that is pretty
interesting Biden is strongest with
black women with black woman he is doing
exceedingly well his 47% of the black
female vote as compared with 18% for
Bernie Sanders and 17% for other but
it's still as I say extremely early in
the game extremely early in the game at
this point so for all the people who are
already saying well you know Biden's got
this thing locked up I don't really see
that so joe biden did his campaign
launch yesterday he was in Pittsburgh
and he's speaking to Union Hall this is
gonna be his chief argument his chief
argument as the International
Association of firefighters guy who
announced him said his chief argument is
I'm the guy who's most likely to be
trumped now I have said for years I
think that's true I think Joe Biden is
the candidate most likely to defeat
President Trump because he is a guy who
has a blue-collar feel a long record
he's a person who's perceived as more
moderate and more comfortable he can run
a back to normalcy 1920 Warren G
Harding's style campaign all he has to
do is stand there people have a level of
familiarity with him that they don't
have with Bernie Sanders Bernie Sanders
is kooky and scary
whereas Joe Biden is kooky and not
nearly as scary so in a general election
that's the case if Joe Biden makes it
through the primaries I think he is a
formidable Challenger for President
Trump my big question is does he make it
through the primaries considering that
the excitement in the primaries is
everything that excitements in the
primaries the ability to mobilize people
in Iowa in New Hampshire for example
that means an awful lot there are new
polls out of New Hampshire by the way
that you Biden vaulting into the lead in
New Hampshire Elizabeth Warren is
picking up no new support in New
Hampshire which means that she's got a
problem on her hands but Biden according
to the latest poll in New Hampshire the
Boston Globe Suffolk poll shows that
Biden has 20 percent followed by Bernie
Sanders at 12 in Budaj
at 12 so Budaj Edge has been gaining
Elizabeth Elizabeth Warren is still
stuck at 8% none of these numbers are
prohibitive however because remember
that the national polls don't matter
nearly as much as the primary polling in
the primary polling Biden has a very
narrow lead over Bernie Sanders in Iowa
in New Hampshire he has a slight
lead over Bernie Sanders in the poll
average and the poll average he's got
maybe one point on Bernie Sanders in
South Carolina he seems to have opened
it up South Carolina's where Biden has
an advantage again because Iowa New
Hampshire are disproportionately white
and South Carolina is disproportionately
black in terms of the voting delegations
so the real question of the election is
going to be do you start to see black
support Wayne for Joe Biden as his
record is reviewed and as Barack Obama
doesn't endorse him we'll get to Joe
Biden actually jumping in what he had to
say and what his campaign looks like in
just a second first some topics in life
are just uncomfortable to talk about sex
is one of those things but sex is also
one of the most important things in life
especially within the context of
marriage studies show that 70 percent of
dudes who experience erectile
dysfunction don't get treated for it for
just that reason it can be awkward to
discuss but sometimes things just don't
work the way they're supposed to and
that's not something to be ashamed about
that's just something to get solved and
that's where our friends at Roman come
in thankfully Roman created an easy way
to get checked out by a doctor get
treated for IDI online Roman is a
one-stop shop where you can chat with a
licensed u.s. physician who can treat
easy and if safe and appropriate ship
medication directly to your door with
Roman there are no waiting rooms awkward
face-to-face conversations or
uncomfortable trips to the pharmacy you
can handle everything discreetly online
all you have to do is visit get Roman
comm /ban complete that online visit
chat with the doctor and if the doctor
decides it would be safe and appropriate
they will ship genuine medication
directly to your door indiscreet
unmarked packaging dudes go online get
checked out by the doctor Eadie can be
embarrassing to talk about but it really
shouldn't be with Roman it's really
simple to tackle so take care of it for
a free online visit go to get Roman comm
/ Ben that is get Roman comm / Ben for a
free online visit get Roman comm / Ben
go check them I got the problem solve
dudes there's nothing to be embarrassed
about just get it solved get Roman comm
/ man alright so Joe Biden launches his
campaign and one of the chief problems
for Joe Biden is that he happens to be
quite old and because he is quite old
he's 77 years old come the time of the
election that means that he is kind of
slurring his words out there his Donald
Trump wants to label Joe Biden's sleepy
Joe which frankly I think is bad
branding because Joe Biden's entire
campaign is I'm a normal guy you can
trust labeling him sleepy Joe like Trump
being high-energy vs. Biden being low
and
is actually not something that cuts it
in Trump's favor because I think that
Biden's basic appeal right now is guys
we need a breath we need a break I mean
this is just too crazy it would be much
better if he had gone with Obama Joe is
something that the labels Joe Biden is
part of the Obama team but he's not
doing that in any case it is true that
that Joe Biden is an old dude and that
is something that is likely to come up
in this election cycle particularly in
the primaries where he's running against
a bevy of younger candidates and even
Bernie Sanders who seems more energetic
than Joe Biden here is Joe Biden
yesterday at the Teamsters temple number
249 in Pittsburgh slurring his words
thanked rich Fitzgerald the county
executive of Allegheny County executor
being here and all my time of public
life for this I've gotten involved the
country wasn't built by Wall Street
bankers CEOs and HUD and hedge fund
manager if the enterprise hit hard times
everybody took a hit union workers the
UAW took incredible cuts in their future
their pensions in the left to get GM
working they also got that last year
okay so I mean he is slurring his words
and his age is gonna be an issue just
like it was an issue for Hillary Clinton
it will give Trump something to run
against him on although Joe Biden will
likely look at Trump and say listen dude
you're like three years the other
effectively speaking this will be a
bunch of old people clubbing each other
for nominations and then the presidency
it's a walker fight so stock up on
tennis balls to make sure that those
walkers move smoothly across the floor
I'm very much looking forward to old
people clubbing each other to death
for the presidency of the United will
the boomers leave us alone well honestly
they my parents are boomers there are
some very wonderful boomers but can we
like move beyond this that would be kind
of nice in any case so Joe Biden then
launches his campaign and the launch of
his campaign is old themes and the
question for Americans is going to be do
we want to go back to the Obama era now
the way that the Democrats are gonna
play the Obama era is a time of peace
and prosperity where we had a popular
president and people came together and
then there's gonna be a lot of folks who
say um no that's not what it was like at
all okay so I think that you are going
to see footage from President Trump of
Ferguson on a loop you're going to see
footage from President Trump of the
Dallas police shootings we're gonna see
footage from President Trump
of of people who are impoverished during
the Obama administration he's gonna talk
about how the economy is much better and
that is Trump's chief appeal I don't
think the Trump can make the case that
he has been a radically unifying
president cuz I don't think that that's
true but the disunity started under
Barack Obama so any idea that Joe Biden
is a unifying figure I think his is
simply not the case like he should be
running with the ads of Joe Biden
suggesting that Mitt Romney was gonna
put black people back in Chains he
should be running ads with Joe Biden
saying that Obama care was a big effing
deal combined with ads of Bernie Sanders
saying that Obama care is a disaster
area but Joe Biden's real appeal it's
really funny the so Donald Trump's great
appeal when he said make America great
again is that he was appealing to an
ideal so Democrats people on the Left
they said America was never great how
can he say America make America great
again like when when there was
segregation when there was slavery when
was America greater than it is now
that's not what he meant by make America
great again as everybody intuitively
understood what Donald Trump meant is
that there is a generalized feeling in
the United States that we are more dis
unified than we have been any time in
recent history and that there used to be
at least a common sense of purpose in
the United States and that common sense
of purpose was moving toward integrating
everyone properly and that americo's
based on fundamentally good principles
and that we had left that during the
Obama era
well now Biden is basically running
Trump's campaign from 2016 he's now
saying the Obama era was the apotheosis
of unity that wasn't true but that's
going to be his appeal he's gonna say
that Donald Trump is even more dis
unifying than Barack Obama so Barack
Obama's period was a halcyon era of
American unity now I'm old enough to
remember that it's not true but you're
going to see Joe Biden make that claim
and that's why he was saying yesterday
he's running to restore the soul of the
nation if you are looking for the soul
of the nation in Joe Biden let me
suggest that you're looking in the wrong
place but here is Joe Biden's moral
pitch the first is restore the soul of
the nation and the second is to rebuild
the backbone of this nation
and the word is to unify this nation we
always do better react as one America
yeah well I'm again old enough to
remember when you were suggesting the
Mitt Romney the most anodyne most
antiseptic cans in American history you
called that guy a in an incipient
slave-owner so don't give me the unity
routine old Joe but again that's what
he's gonna be running on because when
you are running a unity campaign against
somebody as divisive as President Trump
you don't have to be the full unifier
all you have to do is be less divisive
than President Trump which actually is
not all that hard a job remember Hillary
Clinton was divisive for years long
before she did this Joe Biden is
perceived as sort of doltish and
Claddagh SH maybe accidentally did onion
off' eyeing but I think that actually
plays in his favor
then Trump gets to policy and Trump's
policy is more moderate than the
Democratic base and so Joe Biden will be
attacked not only on his history in
terms of race
but he will be attacked in terms of his
own policy so Joe Biden has sort of a
bizarre combination of policies he is
running an old-school Democratic
campaign at the same time suggesting
that Donald Trump's tax cuts should be
repealed but also it's time to start
rewarding work which is an odd thing
since some 80% of Americans received a
tax cut under President Trump's tax cuts
I should know I am NOT one of them
here's Joe Biden they're riding Trump's
tax cuts but then saying that hard work
should be rewarded president Trump's tax
cut for the very wealthy in corporations
we need to eliminate
these special tax breaks in the tax code
that reward special interest let's get
rid of capital gage loophole for
multimillionaires Warren Buffett said it
best he should not pay a lower tax rate
than the Secretary has I'm going to
change that so millionaires agree they
don't pay lower taxes than firefighters
teachers and I go on and on we need to
reward work in this country not just
well okay well this is just sheer
statistical nonsense of course the vast
majority of taxes are paid by wealthy
folks my effective tax rate was close to
50% last year so no I mean this is just
a bunch of nonsense
nonetheless this is this is him making
an old-school Democratic pitch with a
little bit of Bernie Sanders flavor I'm
not sure that the purists in the
Democratic Party won't just say okay
well why wouldn't I just go with Bernie
then why wouldn't I just go pure you
know Biden that makes the case I mean
that this is all lies here's Biden
suggesting that you got nothing from
Trump's tax cuts that it's just simply
untrue again the vast majority of
Americans received a tax cut and again I
should know I am NOT one of them here is
Joe Biden making this case it's hurting
now
the stock market is roaring but you
don't feel it there's two trillion
dollar tax cut last last year did you
feel it did you get anything from it of
course not of course not all that went
to folks at the top in corporations that
pay no taxes the basic bargain used to
exist the Democrats and Republicans to
agree to has been broken and that is you
contribute to the welfare the enterprise
you work for you got to share in the
benefits in the profits okay that is not
true everybody still agrees that you get
to share in the in the profits that is
why everyone in the private sector has
left unions because they felt like the
better chance of getting a raise was not
to be part of a union that was going to
drive down the profit margins of these
various businesses which is why the
biggest businesses in America in America
are not unionized and it's not all that
hard to get a union started under the
National Labor Relations Act the fact is
the government benefits unions that act
is still in full force and if companies
try to quash unions that is punishable
by law Joe Biden however is making the
same sort of case that Donald Trump made
I wonder if that works in the current
economy now maybe it does because the
media have been lying about the economy
and suggesting that the akan
is not all that good and that there's a
huge number of Americans who are going
without still I think that that is I
wonder if that's going to be a
convincing case finally there is Joe
Biden making the defense of Obamacare
and we'll get to in a second watch Oh
Biden's special vulnerabilities here are
here was Biden saying we have to save
Obama care health care was a huge step
forward the ACA in our country Americans
that don't didn't have it before or now
have it 22 million we have to stop this
administration's effort to gut it first
and then we have to move on and finish
the job okay so that's hilarious he's
now defending the ACA and he's calling
it a step along the way so the Obama
administration was lying all those years
I'll explain in a second why this makes
Joe Biden vulnerable first we all know
moms are superheroes capable of pretty
much anything this Mother's Day Tommy
John is here to give her one more
superpower the superpower of comfort
Tommy John's breathable cool cotton
underwear keeps her two to three times
cooler four to five times drier and they
estimate eight to nine times more
comfortable than regular cotton wind
Mother's Day right now with Tommy John
Bowe Tommy John's men and women's
underwear support and no wedgie
guarantee which should have helped me a
lot in high school comfortable stay put
waist bands a range of fabrics that are
luxuriously soft and designed to move
with you Tommy John's air collection
it's made from lightweight breathable
fabric with seamless bonds at edges
comfort and invisibility two superpowers
for the price of one now Mother's Day is
coming up are you still looking for a
gift you'll actually want give mom
life-changing comfort this year with
Tommy John they're their underwear super
comfortable I know because it graces my
buttocks right now some of you might not
be comfortable buying your mom or your
wife underwear well thankfully they have
a gift set featuring luxuriously soft
loungewear and apparel that makes the
perfect present grab them early before
they sell out plus all Tommy John is
backed by the best pair you'll ever wear
or it's free guarantee so if you don't
love that first pair you get a full
refund hurry over to Tommy John's calm
right now
use code Ben for 20% off your first
order that is code Ben for 20% off only
at Tommy John comm that is Tommy John
and Dom go check them out right now so
as I say the big problem for Joe Biden
is twofold one
he is in fact Joe Biden which means that
he has gaffe tastic dude gaffes all the
time and he says things that are
offensive all the time and the media
have not been paying attention to it in
his first couple of days really but I
have a feeling that the backlash to Joe
Biden as inevitable frontrunner is going
to grow we see this with almost every
race there's an inevitable front runner
going in and it's pretty rare the
inevitable front runner wins and when
they do they end up being so wounded in
the primaries that it's hard for them to
go forward in the general Hillary
Clinton is the person who most comes to
mind inevitable frontrunners have a
rough time George W Bush in 2000 was an
inevitable frontrunner and John McCain
give him a lot of trouble so I don't
think this is gonna be an uncontested
primary where Joe Biden just runs away
with it I don't think that Joe Biden is
even capable of hobbling away with it
the other problem for Joe Biden is not
just that he is gaffe tastic but that he
has a history modern American politics
favors people who do not have histories
it favors people who don't have anything
to apologize for this is the big problem
for Joe Biden is that Joe Biden has a
long and checkered history
he keeps apologizing and apologizing and
apologizing is he gonna be able to win a
campaign a simply on apologizing over
and over and over since the beginning of
the year this has pretty much been his
apology tour in January he apologized
for supporting criminal sentencing laws
that help drive down crime in the United
States he did so because those laws are
now considered both passe and unwove
people have said they're inherently
racist nevermind the fact the 1994
criminal sentencing Reform actually
resulted in the single greatest decline
in American crime in history
it's actually something you should be
proud of but Biden has been running away
of his own record
if you don't think khamel harrison cory
booker are gonna eat him alive on this
you're wrong
which is why back in January Biden was
saying I haven't always been right I
know we haven't always gotten things
right but I've always tried he said that
decisions about criminal justice reform
trapped an entire generation it was a
big mistake when it was made that's a
pretty large change from 2016 when Biden
told CNBC he wasn't ashamed at all for
supporting criminal justice reform and
brags quote I drafted the bill so if you
don't think those will be campaign
commercials directed against old Joe you
got another thing coming and then of
course weeks ago has Biden prepped his
presidential run
he approached Anita Hill that's the
woman who accused Justice Clarence Tom
of sexual harassment at the time most
Americans didn't believe anita hill in
the same way most Americans did not
believe Christine Blasi Ford and her
meritless and baseless or evidence free
at least allegations against Brett
Kavanaugh Joe Biden didn't even believe
any to Hill at the time he told Arlen
Specter quote it was clear to me from
the way she was answering the questions
she was lying
now however Biden has told Hill that he
was sorry for what happened to you
that's because the left-wing agitprop
over on HBO has suggested that an Anita
Hill is actually a martyr to the women's
cause despite the fact that she followed
Justice Thomas from job to job despite
the fact that she had told apparently
according to her friends that they she
had told them that Justice Thomas was a
good man and an illegal scholar and that
she had left him all sorts of messages
soliciting his well-being seeing how he
was doing in all of this over the years
now Joe Biden is going around
apologizing to Anita Hill but Anita Hill
says why would I accept your apology you
helped sink my case just three weeks ago
bet Biden issued another quasi apology
for his obituary of women's personal
space it was weird grabbing of faces and
touching of hair
he said the boundaries of protecting
personal space have been reset I get it
I get it
I hear what they're saying I understand
it I'll be much more mindful so here's
the big problem for Joe Biden all the
things that make him attractive to
moderates are all the things he's going
to be apologizing for this puts him
between a rock and a hard place if he
had the courage not to apologize he'd
probably be better off but the media are
going to insist he apologized so that he
is considered sufficiently woke and
that's why the New York Times has an
entire piece today from Lucy Flores
Flores is the former state Assemblywoman
who was running for lieutenant governor
of the state of Nevada and accused Joe
Biden of smelling her hair she has it a
huge piece in the New York Times today
called Joe Biden and the apologies that
weren't and she says the act of atoning
may be difficult and complicated but the
concept is simple enough you did
something bad in a caused harm a basic
sense of decency urges you to take
measures to at worst express how sorry
you are
and it best do something to right the
wrong on the other side of atonement we
find forgiveness one does not happen
without the other history has shown us
that both of these acts are difficult
and yet both are necessary to maintain a
cooperative and functioning society and
then she talks about the me2 movement
and how women are
still being put under the thumb she says
powerful rich and famous men who acted
with impunity some for decades were
finally brought to some version of
justice and then there was Joe Biden not
a villain not an unlikable person not a
sexual harasser assaulter but also as an
ADA he'll recently found out
not exactly sorry either I wrote about
my own experience with mr. Biden last
month about the time in 2014 he grabbed
my shoulders smelled my hair kissed the
back of my head and soon after other
women came forward about their own
experiences with uninvited and unwanted
intimate behavior in professional
settings even though his defenders
reduced the behavior to hugging it was
not and shifted the focus to his intent
it was good intent and made up false
political motives to shift the attention
to me she endorsed Bernie Sanders in
most reasonable people understand that
this kind of behavior with women
violates not just their bodily autonomy
but also demonstrates a lack of basic
understanding of social norms most
people acknowledge men don't usually
kiss smell rub noses with place their
hands on the thighs of or touch
foreheads with random women they don't
know yet some men do especially powerful
men who are protected by privilege and a
crew of self interested in neighbors who
don't want to lose their access to power
by calling out the obvious
if you don't think Kamala Harris or
Elizabeth Warren or Amy clobber char or
kirsten gillibrand I'm gonna hit Biden
with this you are wrong you'll be hit
with all of these things lucy flores
concludes by suggesting he needs to seek
atonement
she says if a candidate has taken some
questionable positions or done or said
some questionable things we must ask
what have they done to show they've
actually learned and evolved ultimately
the easiest way to fairly assess whether
or not someone has truly learned
involved in a tone is to watch their
actions because when people show you who
they are then we should believe them
and this is why Biden is going out there
and trying to claim that he has
apologized to Anita Hill and Anita Hill
is saying I'm not interested in your
apology
here was Joe Biden on the view
suggesting just that he said I take
responsibility for how I need a hill was
trees actually on Good Morning America I
was chairman of the committee I believed
her from the very beginning I but I was
chairman she did not get a fair hearing
she did not get treated well that's my
responsibility and I committed that I am
determined to continue the fight to see
to it that we basically change the
culture in this country where a woman is
put in a position where she is
disbelieved as the
mini Chairman I take responsibility that
she did not get treated well I take
responsibility for that oh do you take
responsibility for that Joe Biden
because I have a feeling Anita Hill is
not going to accept that Anita Hill I
have a feeling is also going about
Camilla Harris for president of the
United States so as I say Joe Biden has
a lot of vulnerabilities maybe those are
all Twitter vulnerabilities maybe those
are in the bubble vulnerabilities or
it's possible that a lot of the in the
bubble of vulnerabilities eventually
break out into the mainstream Joe Biden
has not faced an iota of opposition yet
from the other candidates in the race
not one iota and so he is widely
perceived as the most electable and when
it comes to areas of for example if it
comes to areas of his treatment of women
in a general election he will be able to
point at Donald Trump and say well at
least I'm not that so I'm not sure he's
super vulnerable in a general to all of
that but when it comes to his treatment
of Anita Hill when it comes to his
racial history when it comes to his his
own history of demonizing his opposition
when it comes to his own history of
lying the fact is that Joe Biden lies
with a straight face as well as any
politician I've ever seen I remember in
2012 and he was debating Paul Ryan he
was making things up Paul Ryan didn't
have the base of knowledge particularly
on foreign policy to fight Joe Biden on
this but Joe Biden was making things up
I mean talking about how the how the
Syrians had been cast out of Lebanon
making up American history and Paul Ryan
and then and then grinning his way
through it like the Joker
I don't think Joe Biden is quite as
likable as he seems right now because
this is day one so come back to me in a
couple months if Joe Biden is still
leading but don't tell me that right now
he's leading and therefore he is the
inevitable nominee I have my doubts
about that Bernie Sanders too is going
to be attacking Joe Biden so Bernie
Sanders again gonna go after Joe Biden
on his record I'll show you that in just
one second first it's spring it's the
time of year when seeds grow into
flowers and you grow up financially at
least your family needs protection if
something happens to you that means you
need life insurance thankfully policy
genius makes it easy to get that
financial security without the growing
pains policy genius is the easy way to
buy life insurance online in just two
minutes you can compare quotes from top
insurers and find your best price once
you apply the policy genius team will
handle all the paperwork and the red
tape no Commission's no hidden fees just
financial protection and peace of mind
no strings attached and policy genius
doesn't just simplify life insurance
they also make it easy to compare and
buy home insurance auto insurance
disability insurance so next time you
stop to smell the roses pull out your
phone head over to policy genius.com
policy genius spring is here kick it off
by nipping life insurance in the bud and
by the way do the responsible thing be a
responsible human if you should plotz in
a car accident tomorrow make sure that
your family is taken care of and you're
not tossed into a pauper's grave like
mozart make sure that you are taken care
of in your family has the money
necessary to survive it's part of being
a responsible adult go get your life
insurance policy genius makes it super
easy go over to policy genius comm and
go check it out right now okay in a
second i'm gonna show you how Bernie
Sanders is already opening the
floodgates against Joe Biden we'll get
to that in just one moment first you're
gonna have to go and subscribe over at
Daley we're calm for $9.99 a month you
can get a subscription it's a Lee Weyer
when you do you get the rest of this
show live you get an additional two
hours a day of this show yesterday we
had a bunch of breakouts we had Newt
Gingrich on our on our afternoon show we
also had you Sorrell goldstein who's the
rabbi who was shot in Poway the Chabad
Poway we have great guests nearly every
day plus two more hours of my incisive
and brilliant commentary you get all
that for $9.99 a month are you kidding
me it's amazing it's so good I would pay
for that of course then I'd be paying
myself I'd rather that you pay me but go
check it out right now
for $9.99 a month also for $99 a year
you get this the very greatest and
beverage vessels cast your eyes upon it
and know that were this to be in your
hand right now you'd be infused with the
power of Zeus it's like Shazam kind of
so go check that out right now
also check us out at YouTube and iTunes
leave us a review we always appreciate
that because that's what makes us the
top conservative podcast in America the
fastest growing podcast in America the
fastest growing radio show in America go
give us a listen we were the number two
downloaded podcast in all of America
which means all of the world as of last
month make us number one by going and
telling your friends to listen to our
show at YouTube and iTunes go check us
out we are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so as I say better much better for a
candidate not to have a record than to
have record this is what we find out
from from Barack Obama in 2008 having a
record means you get attacked over that
record so here's Bernie Sanders who has
no record the nice thing about Bernie
Sanders for Democrats dude doesn't have
a record he's said a lot of stuff but
he's never done anything ever he's not
voted for anything he's a useless old
codger a useless old commie and so but
that gives him the ability to yell at
Joe Biden a lot so he slams Joe Biden
over trade deals the fact is that Joe
Biden is trying to crib from Bernie
Sanders his sheet when it comes to his
populist outlook here's Bernie Sanders
trying to crush Biden over it I think
when people take a look at my record
versus Vice President Biden's record I
helped lead the fight against NAFTA he
voted for NAFTA I helped lead the fight
against PNTR with China he voted for it
I strongly oppose the trans-pacific
partnership he supported it I voted
against the war in Iraq he voted for it
okay so obviously all of this is going
to come up and the Democratic base is
gonna have to deal with all of this so
he's gonna get the Joe Biden is gonna
get the you're not radical enough you're
not committed enough you're responsible
for war in Libya you're responsible for
war in Syria you were there for Obama
care which is a giant fail you know Joe
Biden is gonna be able to say Obamacare
is great and Bernie Sanders gonna look
at him and say I know it's not Medicare
for all is great and you want to say
that you gave us a transition you said
Obama care was the final step in other
words there is a lot of dirt on Joe
Biden and none of it has yet really seen
the light of day because it was all it
was all glossed over by the beautiful
candidacy of Barack Obama Joe Biden is
not a beautiful inspiring candidate Joe
Biden is a confused old dude who says a
lot of weird stuff and acts weird so I
do not know that he is going to be able
to simply waltz to the nomination and so
many people think he is now maybe I'm
wrong again I could be wrong I was wrong
about 2016 and Donald Trump's
electability but I do think that we have
not yet begun to see this fight remember
the date it is still April of 2019 the
first primaries are not going to happen
for nearly a year that is a long time
for Joe Biden to fall apart on the stump
so for all of the talk about Joe Biden
being a prohibitive or a formidable
frontrunner I do not think that is
correct okay meanwhile over in Venezuela
things are heating up again so people
sort of forgot about Venezuela
after kuan Widow who is the Venezuelan
opposition leader declared himself the
president of the country Nicolas Maduro
who's a dictator declared no not too
much
and hon widow has been under danger of
rest members of the military have have
refused to join on phyto side well now
he is pushing toward the end game is
quite off on Tuesday he appeared with
troops at a Caracas military base
announcing a final phase to remove
Nicolas Maduro from office he'd be great
by the way for Venezuela for Nicolas
Maduro and his corrupt socialist evil
regime to go kwan widow is not a right
winger by any stretch of the imagination
but at least he is not a full-on
socialist who is attempting to steal all
the wealth for a privileged few while
impoverishing the entire people so
here's what we know for now according to
the Washington Post vice president Penn
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo national
security adviser John Bolton have
expressed us support for the opposition
Maduro says that the military has
remained loyal government leaders
denounced a coup attempt by a reduced
group of military officials and warned
of a counter-attack
so that is them saying we're gonna come
in and maybe we'll slaughter our own
troops quite Oh has urged supporters to
take to the streets for nonviolent
action and claims to have a list of
names of military officials who support
him so we were about to find out whether
or not the people of Venezuela will rise
up and whether the military is willing
to fire on those people on mass the one
thing Maduro has done is ensured that
his top levels are secured by bribing
them effectively according to the
Washington Post quite Oh appeared early
Tuesday to be staging a military back
challenge to Maduro issuing a video with
troops that he said was recorded at a
base in Caracas urging other soldiers to
join the final stage of operation
Liberty meant to force the socialist
leader from power in a second we'll get
to more details so phyto said people of
Venezuela the end of usurpation has
arrived at this moment I'm with the main
military units of our armed forces
starting the final phase of operation
Liberty people of Venezuela will go to
the street with the Armed Forces to
continue taking the streets until we
consolidate the end of usurpation which
is already irreversible meanwhile
majoras Communications Minister
the government was moving to confront a
coup and was attempting to deactivate a
reduced group of military officials for
our traitors
so this could theoretically break into
open warfare in the coming hours outside
the la Carlotta military base in the
Eastern District of Alta Mira where
Hawaii Oh has asked supporters to
assemble people started to join hi toes
call to protest they were met by tear
gas canisters not clear who was firing
the teargas troops supporting quite Oh
appeared to be wearing blue armbands
Maduro said that the military is still
loyal to me he tweeted steel nerves I've
talked to commanders in all the regions
of the country
they've manifested their total loyalty
to the people the Constitution in the
homeland I call from maximum popular
mobilization to ensure the victory of
peace we will win and they're trying to
suggest that why doe is touching off of
violence with peaceful marches the
question is who's gonna fire the first
shot and if the first shot is fired how
this goes and then the question becomes
what American involvement should be
should America be involved in this at
all should they be riding armed support
to white O's military backers white all
has called for non-violent action the
video has the hallmarks of a significant
military challenge his claim has been
recognized quite as claims been
recognized by nearly 60 nations
including the United States the Russians
have been pushing support into the
country as well vice president pence had
tweeted of course to Hahn white or the
National Assembly and all of the
freedom-loving people of Venezuela who
are taking to the streets today in
operation Libertad was s the most
content as we are with you America will
stand with you until freedom and
democracy are restored vaya con Dios and
of course Pompeo has expressed his
support for it as well so if violence
breaks out how much support we should be
providing as much support in my view is
necessary the same way we have provided
support to the rightful opposition in
Ukraine to Russian usurpation Marco
Rubio the senator who is strongly backed
why I don't been very vocal he says this
is the moment for those military
officers in Venezuela to fulfill their
constitutional oath and defend the
legitimate interim president horn Cueto
in this effort to restore democracy you
can write history in the hours and days
ahead it's you know this this is coming
to a head we will keep tabs on it but
the United States should
should provide whatever covert support
short of actual head-on military
intervention is necessary to preserve
quite oh and help this opposition take
power in Venezuela because Maduro is not
only illegitimate he is one of the worst
dictators on the planet he has reduced
one of the most oil-rich nations on
earth to a group of citizens eating dogs
in the streets which is horrifying in
every way and by the way one of the
reasons that you have along with many
other regimes in South America that have
done a terrible job of governing a
citizen in an immigration crisis moving
toward South and Central America up
through the American border meanwhile
Democrats continue to target president
Trump the incoming New York Attorney
General has declared basically that she
wants Trump this is prosecutorial
misconduct honestly to suggest that you
were going after a person not a crime is
prosecutorial misconduct the goal of a
prosecutor the goal of police forces is
to detect a crime and then arrest the
person responsible for the crime is not
to target the person then dig up the
crime it is easy enough for the police
to trump up charges against anybody if
you look long enough at everything that
they are doing not that hard to find
some violation of law well now the New
York Attorney General elect with tesha
James says that that's exactly what
she's gonna do she's going to unfairly
and in corrupt fashion target the
President of the United States she says
that she is going to target Trump his
family and anyone in his circle who may
have violated the law Shaz will use
every area of the law to investigate
President Trump and his business
transactions and that of his family as
well she wants to she wants to
investigate any potential illegalities
involving Trump's real estate holdings
the June 2016 Trump Tower meeting she
wants to examine government subsidies
Trump received she wants to examine
whether he's in violation of the
emoluments clause in the US Constitution
wants to probe the Trump foundation she
doesn't want to investigate anyone in
his orbit who has in fact violated the
law the fact is that when you have
prosecutors who are operating as
freewheeling targeting entities this is
a this is not rule of law this is rule
of men and it is this is evil it really
isn't it would be evil if a Republican
prosecutor decided to investigate Barack
and Michelle Obama just out of animus
for Barack and Michelle Obama again if
you want to target the core
that is one thing that is a good thing
but the fact is that when you have state
prosecutors who are targeting individual
human beings and then trying to find a
crime that is an abuse of power a
serious abuse of power and it's
something that everybody should consider
right left and center how would you feel
if the government came after you and
decided to pin a crime on you or to
uncover a crime that you may have
committed in the past not based on them
uncovering the crime but based on their
dislike for you
this is incredibly incredibly dangerous
stuff it's so funny people will suggest
that when Donald Trump says lock her up
about Hillary Clinton that's out of
animus for Hillary Clinton and that's
terrible and horrible at least he's
identifying a crime Letitia James isn't
even identifying a crime yet she's
saying I hope I find a crime here and I
hate President Trump that's an act of
tremendous corruption supreme corruption
and this is the problem with the
government having this sort of power
generally you have to think about the
sort of power that you hand a government
because it could in fact be used against
you I mean Trump should be a frankly
Trump should sue her for violation of
civil rights based on these sorts of
statements meanwhile Deutsche Bank is
already providing documents on Trump's
financing to the New York state
authorities they're investigating and
demanding records related to loans and
lines of credit granted to the Trump
Organization Trump is trying to sue
Jewish bank to prevent Deutsche Bank
from handing over those documents saying
this is outside the scope of the
prosecution opposition Democrats are
doing the same thing this is unfair
targeting unless they actually have some
evidence of a crime now is that illegal
it is not illegal but it demonstrates
that the American voters need to get
serious about how they implement their
principles if you are happy with
prosecutors whether they are in Congress
or whether they are state's prosecutors
like like Letitia James the New York AG
abusing their power to target
individuals just because they don't like
their politics
this is dangerous dangerous stuff okay
time for some things that I like and
then some things that I hate so things
that I like today so there was a video
yesterday that that emerged of Alma
Perez who's 34 year old uncle who saved
his niece during the Chabad of highway
shooting he picked her up ran her in the
other room
an immigrant from state he had come over
from State Route Israel state roads of
course the city which has been fired
upon by Hamas rockets repeatedly he was
reunited with his niece yesterday in the
video is really beautiful and again
there their real heroes out there every
day doing their best to save other
people all mode parents is one of them
there are many heroes at that particular
congregation is well worth pointing out
the heroes who were running to save
children one hero who ran unarmed an
armed man in attempt to scare him away
a hero who pulled out a gun and shot at
the at the armed terrorists their heroes
everyday and if you're here honestly we
need to arm ourselves we really do and I
mean every good person should be armed
because this is their just too many evil
people out there for there to be any
alternative okay other okay so let's
easy let's do some things that I hate
all right so things that I hate today
this is just an awful story and
demonstrates that when you are a nutcase
driven by partisanship alone you should
I mean this is this is jailable stuff
this is jailable stuff so there's a
story out today there was there's
somebody who tried to put up a story
suggesting that mayor Pete bootie dredge
up South Bend Indiana had sexually
assaulted a man in February it turns out
that this story was just a lie and it
was put together allegedly by Jacob wall
who is just a gross human being and Jack
Burkman another gross human being in the
aftermath of the Brett Kavanaugh saga
they tried to suggest that certain
Democrats were responsible for sexual
assault they wanted to leverage the
allegations and then suggest that well
if you don't back this allegation even
baselessly
then this just shows you're a hypocrite
and so they tried to come up with
apparently false allegations against
democratic figures now they've tried the
same thing with people to judge
according to The Daily Beast quote a
pair of right-wing provocateurs are
being engaged are being accused of
attempting to recruit young Republican
men to level false allegations of sexual
assault against Democratic presidential
candidate Pete Budaj the details of the
operatives attempt emerged as one man
suddenly surfaced with a vague and
uncorroborated allegation that Budaj
edge had assaulted him
the claim was retracted hours later on a
Facebook page appearing to belong to the
man a Republican source told The Daily
Beast that lobbyist Jack Burkman an
internet troll Jacob wall approached him
last week to try to convince him
to falsely accuse boo to judge the mayor
of South Bend Indiana of engaging him
sexually while he was too drunk to
consent the source said their goal was
to kneecap a Buddha chooses momentum in
the 2020 presidential race the man asked
to remain anonymous out of a concern the
resulting publicity might imperil his
employment and because he said whoa and
Berkman have a reputation for
vindictiveness which of course is true
the source did provide the daily beast
with surreptitious audio of the meeting
which corroborates his accounts in it
will appears to refer to Buddha judge as
a terminal threat to president donald
trump's reelection
next year on monday a separate
individual using the name of hunter
kelly published a post on the site
medium on which he alleged that buddha
judge sexually assaulted him in february
that post was tweeted out by david wall
jacobs father and quickly rewritten by
the site big league politics which is
known as a land and ground for
right-wing conspiracy theories kelly
supposed medium and twitter accounts
both say they were created this month
his Facebook page included several posts
Loudon Trump and criticizing Hillary
Clinton and then it turns out that Kelly
when he was identified said I was
unaware this was happening but it is
true that wool and Berkman tried to drum
up false sexual assault allegations
against Buddha judge again this is an
act of evil trying to drum up criminal
allegations against innocent people for
political purposes is evil that is evil
stuff and well and Berkman should go to
jail for this they should I mean if they
were soliciting people to make false
charges if they were that is obvious
state-level criminal criminality just
disgusting and walls should have been
thrown out of the movement long ago I've
always thought that he was it's this is
this is insanity the fact that he has
been able to maintain any level of
credibility whatsoever with any group of
people in the United States demonstrates
the gullibility of people who are
willing to believe anything so long as
it serves a partisan purpose just
amazing just amazing and terrible so
that that is certainly the thing that I
hate today okay final thing that I hate
is it's actually thing that I mildly
dislike but it's just it demonstrates
the hypocrisy of the left so Sports
Illustrated is now featuring a woman in
Halima Aydin who is making history as
the first model to wear a hijab in a
bikini for Sports Illustrated swimsuit
now listen I don't care frankly if a
woman wears a bikini I don't care if
he's job to go to the beach you can wear
whatever you want to go to the beach no
friends has beyond this sort of stuff I
don't think that's appropriate I think
you should be able to wear whatever dumb
swimwear you want I think you should be
able to wear a bikini or a bikini you're
if you're a free human being you get to
choose what you wear but Sports
Illustrated Swimsuit Edition
is not a sales line for swimsuits it is
it is a it is let's be frank about this
it is softcore pornography for the
uninitiated that's what it's what it's
Illustrated Swimsuit Edition is was and
always will be and this attempt to
pretend that it's all about female
choice that's really what's what Sports
Illustrated Swimsuit Edition is it's
really stupid yeah I was one of those
guys and one of the few people in
America I subscribed to Sports
Illustrated for years until they became
so overtly political I could no longer
read their magazine I used to read it
cover-to-cover every single week for
years I was subscribed for probably a
decade I was one of the few people who
actually called up their number and
unsubscribed from the swimsuit edition
you could do that and then get an extra
issue I'm one of the people who took
advantage of that because it was obvious
what the swimsuit edition was I loved
that they're now recasting it as female
empowerment so it's it's women in body
paint hot women and body paint and then
just a lady wearing a swim a wetsuit
which is an interesting tank if you are
gullible enough to believe the Sports
Illustrated swimsuit edition was ever
about anything other than excitable
teenage boys or men who are trying to
have an excuse to look at women in
lingerie or body paint then you are out
of your mind so silly silly Sports
Illustrated and if feminists fall for
this they are really dumb they're really
dumb okay so we'll be back here a little
bit later today with two additional
hours plus make sure that you are here
tomorrow for the next episode of the Ben
Shapiro show we'll see you then I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam SIA
vets audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair
and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
I'm Michael Knowles host of the Michael
Noel's show CNN's Chris Cuomo defends
and Tifa the mainstream media failed to
report on a foiled Islamic terror plot
and leftists embrace the hijab I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Noel's show